if you're looking for a Windows laptop
MSI has got you covered whether it's for
business gaming creating or a mix of
everything while being priced shockingly
low especially during this holiday
season my first laptop that got me
started on YouTube was actually an MSI
because it was thin and light for the
performance it offered while being a
great price that I could actually afford
so when MSI wanted to partner with us I
wanted to Showcase these four laptops
because they offer a great bang for the
buck while all having some unique
features I'll have all the links in the
video description below the first one I
want to cover is the prestige 14 Evo
because the price is unbelievably low
for what you get the design is very
sleek and clean and I like the darker
color and it's surprisingly fingerprint
resistant I still can't believe that you
could buy the I5 model on sale for just
449 dollars during this holiday sale and
not only that but you also get a year of
Microsoft Office 365 included for the
price as well so so it is perfect for
business and productivity now you think
that for that price this thing would
have a cheap plastic build but nope it
is primarily metal and it is lightweight
so it's easy to carry and work on the go
and it's also slim at 0.6 inches while
still having a full-size USB port on the
right side as well as an audio combo
port and a Micro SD card slot on the
left we have two USB type-c ports and
that's what you'll use for charging and
they are regular USB ports but both of
them are Thunderbolt 4 ports so they are
really fast and flexible since you can
use them for external displays while
charging the laptop at the same time
through a USB type-c cable the top cover
is designed so that when you open the
screen it raises the laptop to a 5
degree angle for more ergonomic typing
and the keyboard is surprisingly good
especially at this price the display is
a 14 inch 16x9 1080p IPS panel and the
side bezels are really thin at the top
we have a 720p webcam with infrared so
it supports one of my favorite feature
years Windows hello which logs you in
automatically when you open it up now if
you don't want to use that it also has a
fingerprint scanner built into the top
left of the trackpad now you would think
that for the price it would have slow
connectivity but nope it uses Bluetooth
5.2 and killer Wi-Fi 6E which is
insanely good for the price the same
thing goes for the processor since the
prestige 14 Evo is called that because
it is Evo certified and uses 12th gen
Intel Alder Lake processors which have a
mix of performance and efficiency cores
the base model that's on sale for 449
dollars comes with eight gigabytes of
RAM and for the SSD you would expect 256
gigabyte but it's actually a 512
gigabyte PC Express 4 nvme SSD now the
processor is a 12 Core I5 with four
performance cores and eight efficiency
cores which is combined with a large for
the Size 52 watt hour battery now if you
want to bump up the specs in the
performance for just 200 more you get 16
gigs of LP ddr4x RAM and a one terabyte
SSD along with the bump to a 14 core i7
1280p CPU which we've tested before in
laptops twice the price and gave good
reviews to because it performed the same
unplugged on battery power as it is
plugged in I am still shocked at what
you get for the money including
Microsoft 365 and you can check it out
using the links below the next one is
actually the most expensive but it is
now 650 off the Creator Z16 now I
actually did a full review of this
laptop before and I was impressed
because of the performance for the money
as well as the display this has a
dedicated Nvidia RTX graphics card and a
much more powerful CPU and is designed
for creators and if you're creating the
display really matters this one delivers
because not only is it a QHD plus
2560x1440p resolution but it is 100 DCI
P3 color accuracy with a Delta e of less
than two and each panel is Factory
calibrated and verified by Kalman so
it's perfect for photo editing video
editing and anything else I also love
that it has a glossy display which
retains sharpness and it's a 16 by 10
aspect ratio which is my personal
favorite for laptops since it is great
for creating and productivity as it
gives you 11 more room compared to a
16x9 and it is also a 120 hertz display
and a touchscreen at the top is Windows
slow built in which I wish every laptop
had along with a fingerprint reader the
keyboard is backlit with RGB mini LEDs
and also has good feedback along with
four stereo two watt speakers the design
is Sleek and durable since it is a CNC
unibody design and even though it packs
a lot more performance it is still quite
thin now the Creator Z16 has a large 90
watt hour battery that supports fast
charging for ports we have two powerful
Thunderbolt 4 ports two USB type A ports
that are 10 gigabit per second instead
of being hacked to speed an audio combo
Jack as well as a Micro SD card slot
that is UHS 3 for twice the speed
compared to most inside once again we
have Wi-Fi 6E which is the fastest
standard with a dedicated band that is
less prone to interference as well as
Bluetooth 5.2 and a cooler that is
really slim but has three fans with five
heat pipes to pull the heat out from the
CPU and dedicated GPU you can get up to
a 4.9 gigahertz I9 11900h in this which
did a great job photo editing in my
previous review and a 65 watt RTX 3060
with six gigabytes of dedicated memory
which renders out effects and exports
video really fast with the latest
version of DaVinci Resolve Studio you
can get it with 16 gigabytes of RAM and
a 512 gigabyte SSD to start or go up to
32 gigs of RAM and a 2 terabyte nvme SSD
and in my review I set the specs were
well balanced to work together now if
you are looking for a gaming laptop they
have the ge76 with the 14 core 12 gen I9
12900h processor which will be on sale
for a limited time at only
1479 as you can see this is a whole
different piece that designed with
gamers in mind with its sharp angular
edges and a variety of lighting it is
larger with big vents which are designed
to pull air from the front and exhaust
out the back and the sides and the
cooling system is made to handle up to
220 watts of power now the one for 1479
is actually offered at Costco so you can
pick it up there and it comes with an
RTX 3060 graphics card which also means
that the beefy cooling system will be
able to stay really cool and quiet even
when gaming now I played Call of Duty
Warzone 2.0 which isn't my favorite
genre and it had no issues playing with
good settings but of course MSI has a
ton of options so they have other
graphics cards you can get and the
display on this one is a 17.3 inch full
HD IPS panel that runs at 144 Hertz
which is great for competitive game the
connectivity is also very interesting
with a ton of ports spread on both sides
and the back on the left we have a 10
gigabit per second USB type A and A type
c with Thunderbolt output as well as an
audio combo Jack on the right you get
two 5 gigabit per second usb-a ports
along with a full SD card reader and on
the back we have the charger plug a
dedicated mini display port dedicated
ethernet and an HDMI port that supports
8K 60 or 4K 120 hertz along with a
thunderbolt 4 Port that's a lot of ports
now I mentioned that this is a
gamer-centric design and even though we
do have plastic a lot of the ge76 is
metal of course MSI has their RGB
backlit customizable keyboard but they
also have this unique front bar called
The Mystic light that has RGB lights
built into it that you can customize in
over 16 million colors it also has six
speakers with two dedicated woofers and
an app where you can fine tune and
optimize audio for Media or gaming and
we have a large 99 watt hour battery
which is the biggest size you can
legally fly with you get 16 gigs of RAM
and one terabyte of storage with the
1479 limited time offer so check it out
down below now the next one is very
interesting because it's kind of a mix
of everything with a unique feature and
a killer price of 15.49 being up to 800
off this is the creator 17 so you
guessed it it has a 17 inches play but
what's interesting is that it is a 4K
display which is great but it is a mini
LED display with up to 1 000 nits of
brightness while having a calibrated 100
DCI P3 panel just like the Creator c16
so it's good for HDR video editing it is
thinner than the gaming laptop but still
packs a huge 99.9 watt hour battery
inside with an 11 gen i7 and RTX 3070
graphics card to cut through video
editing or gaming or anything else with
three fans and six heat pipes to keep it
cool you can power it with the included
charger or USB type-c and even though it
looks like it would be too thin it also
has an Ethernet port along with two 10
gigabit per second USB ports in your
audio combo Jack on the left and on the
right side you get a 10 gigabit USBC
Port Thunderbolt 4 an ultra fast SD card
reader and an HDMI with 8K output you
get a black aluminum chassis and the
keyboard has a lot of key travel along
with the fingerprint reader and windows
low so you can see that for 1549 in a 4K
mini LED display you get a lot of value
just like the MSI laptop that I first
bought that allowed me to edit on my
work breaks and caught me into doing
YouTube get this great deal on Amazon or
check out all four laptops and get the
best deals during these sale sales by
using the links down below and let me
know what surprised you the most about
these machines click above to subscribe
and check out another great video right
over there this has been Max and I will
see you in the next one
[Music]